this is why i trust capitalism i just
trust capitalism
spotify
is ruining everything for silicon valley
spotify
is pissing these people off
spotify's making youtubers people who
watch youtube my number one app is
youtube it's my favorite app
i love the app youtube it's got a lot of
potential to change the world it's
changed the world in many ways education
all these other things but to me
spotify is i can guarantee in their
board meetings right now the name
spotify comes up regularly it comes up
in google it comes up in youtube it
comes up in facebook it comes up in
every twitter it comes up in every one
of those conversations they are all
talking about this one company in sweden
called spotify because capitalism works
i'll give you a perfect example
i go to the airport okay are you a utsa
pre are you clear are you also clear i'm
not clear because i don't fly that much
are you clear or no are you tsa you're
just tsa okay so so check this out so
i'm tsa pre and i'm clear and i go to
the airport tsa pre hey yeah hey put
your mask on like i'm [ __ ] sorry put the
mask down my foot cause i forget in
florida like literally i forget every
time people have to tell me clever say
hey do you mind putting a mask on do you
need one we have a clear mask we can
give you here we go we'll give it to you
oh thank you so much okay perfect reason
why capitalism works tsa pre public
company government organization okay
clear private company okay they have to
serve you
they have to service you or else they
don't get business
tsa pre if you tell a tsa pre-employee
what did you say i'm going to write a
negative review on yelp about tsa in
dallas good luck
i don't give a [ __ ] right tell her clear
what's your name johnny no problem i'm
going to write a negative review and i'm
going to send an email please so what
can i do to make you better i'm so sorry
this has been a terrible experience let
me make it better for you what can i do
that's capitalism capitalism is about
serving you
and the government organizations are
like you better listen to me because you
don't have an alternative okay the other
day jen we're going through
i don't know where we're going where
were we last week i don't even know
where we were anyways we're going
somewhere and jennifer's got the milk
because you know she baby's still six
months so she's still going through the
phase of uh
you know
the the all the machines that she's got
to travel with yeah but she has the milk
and she puts it through and the guy's
standing there and it's been 10 minutes
i'm like i got a flat so excuse me is
there any way you can how soon can you
guys take a look at jen's back wait
we'll let you know and walks off i'm
like dude i'd love to slap you upside
the head right yeah but if i do i'm
going to jail if i do that because you
can't do that right that's not customer
service let me get with you in a minute
let me see what i can let me see if i
can get somebody that's tsa so trust
capitalism and long term as long as
capitalism is the core system where
people can compete in the marketplace
product prices will go lower
products will improve websites will get
better experiences will get better
customer service will get better
customer experience in every possible
way capitalism can help make your life
better because they have to compete
think about it like these guys don't
compete is when those things don't get
better i'm listening to what you're
saying and i 100 agree but my mind
immediately goes to schools
because you have kids all around the
country suffering in schools that don't
work and every time someone suggests
vouchers every time someone suggests
charters every every time someone
suggests turning you know bringing the
free market into the educational system
and and doing something actually doing
something about that democrats come back
and say well no it's just more funding
that we need anytime we've been giving
funding to to schools for so long more
and more more money and it doesn't
produce this was the whole thing with
betsy devos right that's exactly she got
vilified if you watched anything on the
left you think she's the most evil
person ever she was about school
vouchers and that's essentially
capitalism
the reason you know you asked me in the
beginning if this was my hill to die on
the vaccines and i said it's not about
vaccines for me it's about freedom it's
about empowering people it's about you
have a kid and you have one school in
your district and that school is failing
and you want the opportunity to take
your child into a better school system
into a better school and you can't do
that i want to empower that family to be
able to do that i want to force those
bad schools to perform better by having
to compete with a really good school
that now kids are flocking to
and again the reason people on the left
often oppose all of these things is
because it removes power from government
and it removes power of government over
you government then can no longer tell
you what school you put your kid into
and once people realize that they don't
need government for those things that
they can rely on themselves that they
have some freedom in society they can
build their own lives that they get to
keep more of their hard-earned cash all
of those things government becomes less
and less powerful less and less needed
and the politicians that are espousing
big government
lose favor with the public so the whole
system is broken because of a lack of
freedom so i was talking education
because i came out of education in
television first now i'm talking about
vaccines i could be talking about
anything but what i'm really talking
about is freedom that is a hill i will
die on more so now because i have a
two-year-old and i'm increasingly
worried about the world that he's coming
into i want him to be a free thinker i
want him to live freely i want him to be
able to build the life he wants for
himself and make his own choices for his
own health and his own family
and i want people who are going to be an
obstacle to that to be voted out of
office and to get out of his way so he
has given me
a great sense of of of motivation and
power at this time and i just think of
his face and i'm like this this is worth
fighting
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]